michelle obama urgent message
about this year's midterm elections this
is a cnn story former first lady
michelle obama has a message for
americans ahead of 2022 midterm
elections we've got to vote like the
future of our democracy depends on it
we've heard this a million times in a
letter titled fight for our vote which
was published sunday
as an ad in the new york times obama
called an amer on americans to continue
emerging engaging in democracy amid a
historic attack on voting rights obama's
letter referenced the insurrection and
the uh the what is that i wrote over it
and is it a slew of young voters voting
restrictions pass on state law across
the country in its wake senate majority
leader chuck schumer has vowed the
chamber will vote on whether to change
the senate's legislative filibuster
rules uh by martin luther king jr
january 17 of republicans block
democrats latest effort to advance
voting rights legislation do you think
michelle obama is just kind of getting
in there because behind closed doors
there's any aspirations of 2024 they've
been trying they've been banging her for
years she's she's the highest curated
member in the entire democratic party by
far so they've been possibly in the
country
possibly in the country sure so
they they've been they've been trying
she's not for some reason probably
because life's pretty good for them
right now mm-hmm and
i don't know if if they have the same
listen when obama ran the first time
cakewalk as soon as he got passed
as soon as he got past hillary
as soon as he got past hillary it was a
cakewalk anybody who ran against you
know bush was going to be you know
was going to win anybody who ran against
bush's last year exactly you probably
mean mccain
right so in the middle of the great
recession sure he had it
stacked against him right yeah and then
romney for
reasons unbeknownst to anyone took the
gloves off and stopped campaigning with
two weeks to go and a five-point lead
when obama was was doing horrible things
and in the second raid after running
against
after running against bush i i was there
when christie gave him your boy chris
yeah so listen
there's a reason michelle hasn't ran yet
i think that she likes being the king
maker i think she likes having her
netflix gigs i think she likes being a
socialite there's there's a lot that
goes into running where i don't think
they want to have things exposed they
don't want to have to answer hard
questions and a lot of their this is the
other side of it a lot of their playbook
has been run into the ground
there's only so much more division
there's only so much more divide and
conquer you can do
so you know the rules for radicals
things kind of played out now it's we're
going on 20 years right of rules for
radicals here it's
there's at some point they've they've
kind of divided everybody that was going
to divide they found everybody that was
going to vote along the lines of
immutable characteristics and it is what
it is right and matter of fact there's a
lot of statistics showing that the
the identity politics and the latinx
stuff is actually turning off the latin
voter it's turning them off that's
correct so you know that
everything has its time right so is
michelle obama gonna run i don't think
so it's a long answer to say i don't
think so but i do think that she wants
to have the power to decide who runs
which is what i think what she really
wants i think that she wants someone
like stacey abrams and when they keep
and we gotta stop
letting these people frame this issue
the way that they it's a voter rights
issue no it's a freaking
show prove who you are i it draws me out
of my mind the hypocrisy
and adam it's democrats democrat
hypocrisy drives me out of my mind
because they don't care about hypocrisy
the fact that i have to show a vaccine
card to get a sandwich in new york city
is somehow fine
but asking someone to show id to prove
where they are to vote on who runs the
country is somehow racist it's insanity
it's pure and sad this has nothing to do
with voter rights this is their ability
to harvest votes this is their ability
to have the dead vote this is their
ability to know exactly how like what
happened in new jersey you know you go
to bed and and chicarelli is winning by
three percent in bergen and you wake up
oh we found three million melon votes in
bergen county oh well you know
sorry guess murphy's going to be the
governor for the next four years
rising to the two million people that
actually live here yeah you know it's
just insane it's pure insanity man so
listen i mean
and then they they just change history
all the time this goes back to the you
know with the with the you know they
take down the videos it's fahrenheit 451
they're burning the books they're lying
there's hypocrisy but they don't care
because at the end of the day it's all
about
moving their narrative forward they
don't care about lying they know because
again they're not beholden to me and you
they're beholden to international
community they care what putin thinks
she thinks justin trudeau thinks they
don't care what mean you think because
honestly it doesn't matter to him well
the one thing i agree with michelle
obama or michael is that there is a
historic attack on voting rights going
on
yeah
i don't know the citizens vote is being
minimized
the way you did that was very slick but
let me say something to you g i actually
agree with a lot of what you had to say
especially with like the latinx stuff
and
and all that i will say that i've never
been one that has even thought that
michelle obama was gonna run even when
we talked about it uh in the last
primary season which was uh 2019 2020
and it was still bernie was still in it
and you know klobuchar was still in it
beat buddha judge and and you know
bloomberg showed up and people started
throwing around buzzwords michelle obama
michelle obama i was always like why
would she do it why would she do it like
it doesn't make sense i don't see it you
said the q score she is the number one
in the country behind my belief i love
her
the country loves her women love her
country will love her okay you said the
highest q score yeah yeah pull that up
pull up in the democratic party she's
she's equally as the highest q scorer in
the country i decided i'm not even
giving you my opinion just pull it up
but the point is this i think that the
the democrats are going to get squashed
in the midterms and i think someone's
going to say in her ear
biden's ain't going to run anymore like
i think trump is going to run and what a
what a choice between michelle obama and
donald trump yeah and i feel like for
the first time this is where i'm
actually giving credence to her
possibly running i will say so i really
don't i think i think trump would be the
worst case scenario because she couldn't
bully him they she she's a bully he
couldn't bully her she's a bully
politician she wants to run as a victim
but it's impossible to see them as
victims anymore i don't think she wants
to run as a victim how could she play
the victim when she stopped fighting
politics non-stop
pull up the q score
but the point is this regardless i for
the first time actually think that she
would consider running by by the way
forget about whether you you like her
you don't like her etc etc i think she's
the best candidate they got i think
she's the best candidate give me a
better person than michelle obama to run
i can't that's my fault forget about the
democratic party yeah give me one better
joe manchin
for them not for them for you that's on
them democrats wouldn't get behind joe
manchester absolutely they would they
would not get behind how many democrats
hate joe mentioned you saw the
charlemagne the god interview with
kamala harris
i don't think that i i don't think that
that is the i think that's the loudest
voice in the room of the democrats i
don't think that's the prevailing
democrat
look at that
mansion bro so anybody else anybody else
okay so joe manchin is a candidate
the rock is better than michelle
i'm saying yes
but you're saying the rock is more
capable of winning than michelle no no
michelle's the best candidate there okay
yeah i agree i'm just saying the rock's
pretty anybody else give me another one
give me no current politicians zero
current politicians in the democratic
party no if there's someone like tom
hanks was showing up this current this
current incarnation of democrat party is
so unlikable i think that's what the
question is who else that's pat's
question and the question is if if biden
is primaried it's going to come from the
far left but none of those have national
electability after the smoke clears
you have michelle obama with national
electability you've got joe manchin
who's kind of on the other side of the
lightning rod where the the far lefts
are going to completely throw up all
over that so the really the question is
who else if if he's going to be
primaried and it's going to be a
credible national candidate right now
michelle obama is the only only name so
let me go to the so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you